y is directly proportional to x if y
equals 30 when x is equal to 6 find the
value of x when y is 45. so let's just
take this each statement at a time y is
directly proportional to x that's
literally just saying that y is equal to
some constant times x this statement can
literally be translated to y is equal to
some constant times x y is directly
proportional to x
now they tell us
if y is 30 when x is 6
so y is 30 when x is 6 and we have this
constant of proportionality this second
statement right over here allows us to
solve for this constant when x is 6 they
tell us y is 30 so we can figure out
what this constant is and we can divide
both sides by 6
divide both sides by 6 and we get
we get this left hand side is 5. 30
divided by 6 is 5. 5 is equal to k or k
is equal to 5. so the second sentence
the second sentence tells us
this gives us the information that y is
not just k times x it tells us that y is
equal to 5 times x y is 30 when x is 6.
and then finally they say find the value
of x when y is 45. so when y is 45 we
have 45 is equal to
so this we're just putting in 45 for y
45 is equal to 5x divide both sides by 5
to solve for x
we get 45 over 5 is 9 and
and 5x divided by 5 is just x so x is x
is equal to 9 when y is 45.